à paris au musée d'art moderne jusqu'au
18 avril se tient la première grande
rétrospective du peintre américain mark
rothko rothko appartient à la génération
des peintres abstraits de l'après guerre
c'est un énorme succès populaire
actuellement cent mille visiteurs depuis
le 14 janvier au musée d'art moderne
devant les toiles de rothko chacun
raconte son émotion
sous l'oeil de la caméra d'hervé pozzo
avec les commentaires de daniel wolfromm
une heure d'attenté en moyenne pour
rothko maître de l'abstraction
américaine
la chose est inattendu reconnaît le
musée d'art moderne
certains amateurs d'art aussi sans
surprise attendait pas du tout avoir la
queue en général on voit là que pour les
expositions van gogh ou
boga en fait pour une partie du public
la peinture abstraite reste une terre
inconnue quand ce n'est pas du tout et
j'ai découvert et
les couleurs je découvre mark rothko
vite juif russe émigré aux etats-unis
avec sa famille au début du siècle
en 1938 il devient citoyen américain et
expo sous le nom de mark rothko
le voici en 1951 parmi les artistes de
l'avant garde américaine protestant
contre le conformisme des musées de
l'époque désormais ses surfaces colorées
sont devenus des classiques
quand vous regardez cette peinture
disait-il vous devenez cette couleur
vous en êtes entièrement saturé
à ceux qui pensent qu'on est peintures
sont sorel j'aimerais dire que j'ai
impressionné la violence la plus absolue
dans chaque centimètre carré de leur
surface
en effet c était tout sauf une peinture
décorative évidemment c'est pas une
peinture de complaisance il a toujours
fixée à la peinture fut-elle abstraite
et justement parce qu'elles étaient
âpres est un enjeu un contenu qui avait
à voir avec ce qu'il appelle au fond la
tragédie de la vie humaine c'est à dire
la vie la mort qu'il n'était pas du tout
religieux dont il n'a cessé de
s'interroger
interrogé un niveau très élevé sans
avoir véritablement de réponse alors là
c'est tableau s'assombrit de plus en
plus qu'est ce qui se passe il
ils expliquent pas dit je constate qu'à
partir à 57-58 mes tableaux se sont
assombries
en effet c'est comme si comme si
l'artiste est brûlé à trop de lumière et
comme si le feu était de plus en plus
intériorisée gagne en profondeur d un
tableau ce qui permet des dents on inc
l' extérieur malades fatigués seul en
février 1970 mark rothko se suicident
ses dernières compositions rectangle
noir et gris juxtaposés sont le reflet
de son âme
les impasses dans sa vie comme dans son
travail de peintre